hi I'm George Washington the first
president united states and I'm Abraham
Lincoln I was president sometime after
him so if i get this state of the union
tonight we're here to talk about the
state of personal technology
I cannot tell a lie back in the 1700s
things are very very hard for instance
when I chopped down a cherry tree I had
to use a hatchet it took me hours try
building a log cabin with only a hatchet
now for today's woodcutting needs we
have things like this yes this is the
steel 2 30 C now this is a chainsaw it
uses an internal combustion engine you
apply to wood in the treatment fall back
down and how exactly does it work I mean
how many hours of chopping can you get
done you can get done about six hours of
shopping on one tank of petrol some sort
of thing that seeps out of the ground
and they cook it and then and clean it
and put it in here and it drives the
engine back and forth so George how much
would something like that actually cost
300 American dollars do you know how
many electric beard trimmers I can buy
for that money my goodness what does the
missus think of this it has a vacuum
inside that can collect there well slow
down Thomas Alva Edison what is a vacuum
a vacuum is a space in which neither of
us can breathe or exist thus mrs.
Lincoln does not have to clean up the
sink because there won't be little bits
of hairs everywhere I bet that doesn't
know her greatly Martha and I never
fight except for one thing my teeth why
don't you just brush them because she
brushes one widely dispersed during the
1700s however in 2010 this is an
electric toothbrush so what you sound
ways to end vibrations to loosen the
plaque and other food particles that on
your teeth and also force water min
before you go now by cleaning them and
give you a much much better brushing
experience so it's a lot like flossing
but with electricity also you take your
toothbrush head at the end of evening
and you place it in this chamber shut
the chamber and then ultraviolet light
disinfect your brush well in addition to
personal health personal safety is
pretty high on my list I understand you
had an incident at Ford's Theater I got
shot point-blank range when I was just
at the theater it's pretty unfortunate
so Lincoln doesn't mess around anymore
George
what could this deflect musket fire the
thing with the advanced combat helmet is
that it will not stop a bullet at close
range which probably would not help
myself however it does send a very clear
message John Wilkes better luck next
time so what are you gonna do thing I
think I'm gonna go home and emancipate
this face from my beard all right you
know I'm going to do what it will carve
my face in the side of a mountain with
this